don't bring anyone love into this you
know can we do it would you rather I
kind of feel like I want to do the one
we did Ferrari with a bird I'm not sure
what it is let me see how do you find
these fans this is unsolicited somebody
just maybe a so given in India I tell
y'all frustrating that is if I got this
that person would have my phone number
and my address
yeah that's the relationship of that fan
I'd be like dude I really owe you
yeah Oh call me whatever okay I wish
yeah I have no fucking fans like that
Julianne about your boundaries there's
some oh you have a folder called Berta's
fat videos oh yeah Burt our cordova
grace that is that you doing good
crusher you are a fat cats Tom Segura
might yeah there's so many man
international
[Laughter]
and you are better then Tom no people
just made these men like dozens and
Razzles whirl all over the world that is
over fucking well maybe isn't that crazy
awesome I mean these these came in
literally by the dozens man from all
over the life the best one ever is that
fucking pig dude who won the eating
contest that was great not just a
competitor but the favorite to win I
love this guy it's the most you can eat
in five minutes so Richard I how often
oh my god I know my you know my parents
might fool you I've been on a giant diet
and life-changing stuff dropped about a
hundred pounds in eight months awesome
so we're gonna consider this my cheat
day for the year but you know prepping
these gallons of water you know I have
two giant inspirations first my wife
that's alright second anniversary I want
to say hi to her and there's a comedian
I love he's a big giant fat guy just
like me Burt Chrysler actually saw him
recently where he lost yeah one of
somewhere I don't remember somewhere
that I was recently he gave me gave me
like a jersey from one of the kids like
for one of those contests he lost a
bunch more weight really yeah yeah yeah
yeah but he um yeah dude there's there's
I'm blown away by that I get nothing
from Vince no I don't like I mean well
maybe I do but I just don't I don't have
like an email box that I look in maybe
that's the problem you need an email
yeah and then people send it to you
this is another song so many songs yummy
songs his wife Athena made a hashtag
[Music]
literally go hey man you're not that fat
of course and then I go yeah no shit and
they're like I thought you'd be huge
I was like wait are you fucking kidding
me yeah some guy said some guy saw me in
DC this day the other day and he goes
dude you're skinny and I was like I was
like I'm not skinny and he goes whoa
joe said you're 265 I thought you're 265
I go joe said you were 385 at one point
and I go no I'm not
265 and I go it sits and then it starts
making you crazy you go I go you know
Tom was fatter than me when this started
right and they were like no I go hold on
and I was like could he scrub the
Internet of pictures of him no it was
you know what I I think I said this back
then I think some people didn't know
some people did not know some people
knew that I was fatter than you but that
they got a thrill out of spreading the
misinformation it's like you got a fake
news article you want to start Thomas
drunk yeah great idea actually and then
some people were like fuck no Bert's
definitely not as fat fart
[Music]
fart the best this was the best one this
is my I solicited this in my car
this was my favorite song that it's ever
been submitted I think it's one of my
top five really good this is all easy
sir
yeah such a good
like you can look nice in your car yeah
I love this man let's listen to us good
do bleep
[Music]
it's a real song yeah my class
this
great
[Music]
there we go there's just so many songs
is it maybe you just have one fan who's
really busy it's a lot
it is a lot that's fucking insane it is
[Music]